the a desert of isms socialism socialism
as an idea has been around since
antiquity with some arguing that the
teachings of Jesus Christ and the
Prophet Muhammad were themselves
socialist socialism is in essence the
idea that when a business does well the
workers not the owners ought to receive
the rewards that hold whether the
business in question is a farm a high
street bank an online retailer or a
social media company but how to achieve
that that's where it gets complicated
for some socialists the best way to do
that is for the workers to become the
owners that might mean through a
cooperative where a firm's employees
collectively own it and all share the
profits or it could be the government
steps in and nationalizes it as Prime
Minister Clement Attlee did when he
nationalized the commanding heights of
the British economy from the railways to
the post offices in the late 1940s and
early 50s for others who owns a business
isn't that important through taxing the
rich and using the proceeds to pay for
schools hospitals and transport and
through setting minimum levels for how
much workers should be paid the benefits
of a business can be redistributed from
the owners to those who put in the hard
labor to make it happen or as the French
Socialist Sehgal owner output it for
wealth to be redistributed it has to be
created socialism really only acquired a
concrete theory in the nineteenth
century when the philosopher Karl Marx
laid out what he saw as the driving
force behind the revolutions and was
sweeping Europe that helped to inspire
the formation of a number of political
parties throughout the continent
including the British Labour Party after
that socialists put into two different
groups social democrats who wanted to
moderate the global economic system so
it worked in a broadly similar way but
benefited workers not bosses and
communists who wanted to replace the
global order with an entirely new way of
running the economy some say the problem
with socialists ideal is human
development is based on the profit
motive we do things to benefit ourselves
and our families not other people by
taking the benefits of enterprise away
from the bosses we disincentivize
everyone from working and we all get
poorer workers and bosses alike some
socialists thought this criticism had
more than a grain of truth they wanted a
new form of socialism than benefited
workers and bosses alike they
called this the third way between
traditional supposedly unfashionable
socialism and the unrestrained markets
favored by right-wing parties in the
1980's socialism at least as far as Karl
Marx understood it was dead and gone
forever elite until the global financial
crisis when the costs fell on workers
and most bosses escaped unscathed
in the wake of the financial crisis
Moses got very angry and supporters of
the Third Way took a lot of the
electoral pain many voters particularly
the young started to think that perhaps
a return to old-style socialism not
social democracy was the way forward
socialism is back and political
supporters have gone back to its roots
advocating four-day weeks a basic income
and government control over much of the
economy ten years after Marx version of
socialism was declared dead there are
whispers of a resurrection
you